el descontento social sigue golpeando
argentina con cientos de manifestantes
reclamando que el estado asegure unas
condiciones de vida dignas ya que aunque
la economía nacional se está reactivando
y el desempleo ha disminuido respecto al
año pasado la pobreza aún alcanza al 37
3% de la población
está reclamando por partidas
alimentarias para los comedores
comunitarios el aumento de la asistencia
social porque hoy quién puede vivir con
16 mil pesos que es el costo de la ayuda
social de un plan social y además en la
necesidad con la que se viene reclamando
hace años para generar trabajos camino
lejos de lo que propone el gobierno un
descontento agravado por el reciente
trato del gobierno con el fmi para
refinanciar la deuda generada durante el
gobierno de mauricio macri y denuncian
que el dinero saldrá de los subsidios de
los argentinos y afectados por la aguda
inflación y la pérdida del poder
adquisitivo en el país y es que a pesar
de tener un empleo formal muchos
argentinos no llegan a cubrir una
canasta base no solo que avanzaron en el
acuerdo para firmar esta entrega esta
entrega de soberanía de derechos de
futuro de riquezas de recursos que están
firmando sino que además en esta semana
nos mandaron todos los tarifazos del
petróleo el pan la harina en las
algo que también ha generado discusiones
internas en la coalición gobernante
especialmente entre el presidente
alberto fernández y la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner en contra
del acuerdo con el fmi un desacuerdo que
divide a sus propios seguidores